[Musique]
méfiez-vous des apparences derrière ses
chorégraphies millimétrées au quart de
tour et ses visages des faibles se cache
une redoutable machine politique et des
millions de fans capable d'influencer la
politique internationale on a
l'impression qu'il ya comme vraiment une
famille qui se construit qui sont assez
soudé
[Musique]
en juin les fans d' équipe pour
contribuer à gâcher un rally de donald
trump qu'en faisant de fausses
réservation le présidence vente et qu'un
million de personnes ont manifesté leur
intérêt
dans les faits seulement 6000 se sont
présentés on est loin des sauf que les
fans à l'extérieur de la corée qui
suivent ces groupes là des jeunes
sensibilité peut-être un peu plus grande
envers les enjeux le racisme les enjeux
de respect des droits des minorités lgbt
cul parce qu'on en retrouve beaucoup ici
par exemple dans les fans de ces gros
plan dans la foulée du mouvement black
rider à l'invitation du populaire kobe
thiès les femmes ont récolté des
millions de dollars qui se sont
également mobilisées pour les victimes
de l'explosion de déroute les groupes de
grippe a sont un des atouts de la
diplomatie culturelle ce que réelle
son industrie culturelle pourra aider à
diffuser ce produit leur camp ils sont
rendu compte que ça avait elle au niveau
économique ou de leur passion commune
les fans de kpop utilisent des réseaux
sociaux pour devenir une force citoyenne
on sait qu'on a un pouvoir avec mel la
plate forme qu'on appuie l influence qu
on a sur les réseaux sociaux
ils savent comment faire monter des mots
clics dans l'algorithme ils savent par
exemple comment inondés dans le cas de
la police de dallas qui à un moment
donné voulait se servir des téléphones
cellulaires des gens pour identifier des
manifestants ce qu'elles ont fait c'est
qu'ils ont inondé l'application de la
police de dallas avec des films de leurs
vedettes préférées
et ça complètement fait dérailler cette
application l'a visiblement si la k-pop
donne envie de bouger et donne aussi
envie de s'impliquer et de faire bouger
les choses
si nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal